good morning it's morning here today I
want to talk about a familiar subject
which is this whole issue of passive
learning and active learning we had a
comment on our format link someone asked
if perhaps the active or the passive
knowledge of the language is processed
in a different part of the brain than
the active skills in the language I
don't know of course I'm not a
neuroscientist but what I have read and
I've read quite a bit on how the brain
learns suggests that a lot of areas of
the brain are involved in language
learning
and card honestly I don't see how it can
be processed in different parts of the
brain because as we you know learn a
language what initially is
indiscriminate noise eventually as
neural networks are formed as I
understand it we are able now to
distinguish in this what is initially
indiscriminate noise where one word ends
and the new where it begins and
eventually we can start making meaning
out of what was once noise and obviously
when we go then to use this then we have
to be drawing on those neural networks
we can't be charging off it seems to me
to some other part of the brain to start
producing the language but I'm not a
neural scientist although I always
recommend the book by manfred spitzer
called learning or the brain or
something like that and I checked at
Amazon it's not available in English I
have the book here in German before
getting further into this subject of
active and passive I would like to raise
a complaint that I have with YouTube I
love YouTube I think it's a tremendous
community it's a tremendous way to
improve your language skills when I do
you know foreign language videos
especially in languages I'm not very
strong in I often have to do one or two
takes before I I managed to get through
without too many mistakes and watching
yourself speak in another language and
watching your and listening to your
mistakes is a great way to notice where
your gaps are so it's and I I've often
felt that we should as we go along I
guess I haven't been doing this but if I
were more serious I would you know make
videos of ourselves at different stages
and are learning and Justin to see how
we progress so YouTube is great here's
what annoys me with YouTube
every so often a comment you know below
one of my videos says this comment has
been removed because there were too many
negative votes why would you to do this
I don't mind people disagreeing with me
I don't mind people disagreeing with
what other people have to say I don't
mind people calling me an idiot a gasbag
or whatever they sometimes call me a
fool it doesn't matter if I find a
comment offensive because it contains
you know vulgar language or because it's
whatever racist or something I'll just
block it for those reasons but that
decision should be left with me it
shouldn't be up to some automatic
process and I don't know what that
process is I don't know how many
negative votes but but why I look I
cannot understand why they would do
something this it just blows my mind
that's the one thing the other thing is
I noticed sometimes that some comments
are withheld or something and then I go
to that person's Channel and YouTube and
the comment is still there I suggest
this is also something that YouTube does
that eliminates some cards I don't know
if other people have had the same
problem and I guess the third and the
litany of complaints I have about
YouTube is they have made it a little
easier to comment to for me to reply to
comments and I get lots of comments and
I would like to reply it used to be
you'd have to you know click to answer
and then you would be left searching for
the comment and amongst this whole list
of comments now they've got it so that
you click to reply you go
that video and the box two replies below
the comment but thus the video comes on
all the time so then you have to go and
shut down the video so you don't hear
your self talking all the time this is
especially the case if I'm sitting in
the office I don't want to disturb other
people so just some quick comments about
things that annoy me at Google and at
least at YouTube and I wonder if other
people have had a similar comment one
last thing that annoys me is the ads and
that's where we stopped doing our ads
here you know we thought we put some ads
on there to earn a little bit of revenue
to pay for coffee in the office but
really it's so annoying whenever I open
another video and I have to listen to
three seconds or 15 seconds of an ad so
we stop doing that but I understand that
YouTube has to raise money somewhere for
the wonderful service normally wonderful
service that they provide getting back
to passive versus active you know in
some ways it connects with this whole
and you know there's sort of two schools
of thought that we're going to language
learning one says you know speak from
day one and the other says no you need
to build up your knowledge through a lot
of input activities I must say I'm more
in favor me my own method of of language
learning is basically to focus on input
for a period of time that can be two
months six months twelve months it
doesn't matter it depends entirely on
when I either have an opportunity to
speak or a need to speak or I want to
speak but I'm not I don't feel this
compulsion to speak now they speak from
day one people if we use Benny as an
example he likes to get a phrase book on
his way over to some place and kind of
lead through the phrase book and now
he's ready to go and he can start
speaking I don't understand if you're
prepared to because the language has to
come from outside you so that you have
to begin with passive because you don't
have the language in you when you first
go to listen it's just noise so you have
to train the brain to get used to the
language you have to acquire some words
and phrases so why would you limit
yourself to what
a little phrase those traces first of
all you have no concept about whether
those phrases are in fact valid like the
phrases don't have any credibility
because you haven't heard them in
different contexts than just a phrase
you're almost reluctant to use it and if
you do use it you certainly won't
understand what comes back at you so
I've never quite understood that and I
think that that however if people want
to speak from day one like I'm one of my
big main positions is do what you want
to do so if that makes you happy as
crashing point set but you're really
benefiting from there is that you're
being exposed to the language your own
output in my opinion is relatively
unimportant what really matters is
what's coming back at you so that you
may think that you're actually active
but in fact you're mostly passive
because there's very little that you can
say and you have to build up the ability
to understand that as I've said before
now some people claim that they're very
good that they understand but they can't
speak maybe there are such people most
people that I have come across who claim
to understand but they unable to speak
if I speak to them at a normal rate of
speed speech they don't understand what
I'm saying I have yet to come across a
person who understands me very well and
who can't speak these people might exist
I haven't come across such people there
are people who claim that they can read
and write but cats be fine I mean there
are people who have psychological
hang-ups about speaking so they may be
able to write very well and that would
indicate that they have good you know
active skills in the language and they
read and that's okay but they can't you
know speak because they're afraid to
sound foolish yeah would that person
have benefited from speaking from day
one I don't know I think in my own case
I I think it's it may be that might be
but it might also be that that there's
there's so frustrating and stressful to
speak when you have very few words and
don't understand what the other person
is saying that for a lot of
people that would only inhibit the more
I think a lot of people have trouble
speaking are too obsessed with grammar
too obsessed with getting it right and
therefore they're as they're speaking
they're kind of second-guessing
themselves it's a bit like golf if you
just go up there and swing the club
you're probably gonna do better on a
golf course then if you try to think of
where to put your elbow and your knee
and your shoulder and all the little
details of the golf swing and I think I
have a suspicion that those people who
struggle to become active in the
language in fact are too obsessed with
with being perfect and with trying to
remember all their grammar rules by the
way I made some notes here when I was a
student in Europe I was in Vienna I
think we ran a bar talking with
different people there was a fellow
there it was Japanese and who was deaf
and dumb and he could write mean
fluently people would ask him questions
in Farsi and French in Russian you name
it and he would write on the answer and
talk to you you know by writing in these
languages so there's an extreme case of
someone who can read and write and hear
but can't speak but that's not because
he wouldn't have been able to develop
those skills he was unfortunately unable
to he was mute sorry did I say doesn't
dumb he wasn't never done you know what
I don't remember
maybe we wrote to him and rewrote back
anyway a remarkable person a remarkable
person so you know and so what is
passive input again I think some people
think you can just turn the radio on in
the background or watch movies that you
don't understand again if you like doing
that that's fine personally I've never
found that useful I always want to
listen to something where I can get a
transcript and work at it as I do at
Lake I mean ask to me the big thing or
is I bring these texts in I I say the
words and phrases I reviewed them and so
I'm mining is content for words and
phrases and and increasing my my
alertness and attentiveness to the
language and I find that process
eventually gets me to where I can start
speaking at first with difficulty
and then and then you know better and
better as I go so in fact there's
something quite active about the passive
nature of input because you are
interacting with the language you're
making meaning of that language and of
course I've always found like
maintaining my language if I get a call
from the local Chinese television
station they want me to appear on some
program you know I listen to my CDs
Chinese CDs for a few hours that day and
on my way driving to the television
station and that refreshes it so that at
least to that extent
not only have I found that that a lot of
input has helped me like in Romanian
that's the bulk of what I did in there
and there within a month you know I
started speaking so it depends on when
you want to how comfortable you feel
your knees I was going to Romania I had
to start speaking earlier and of course
Romanian had the advantages having so
much vocabulary from from Italian but
I'm gonna make a video here in Spanish
this week so what I did is I went and
got a book a book that I bought the last
time I was in Spain and I'm really
enjoying it and it helps to reactivate
my Spanish and by the way I'll toes I
was saying that I Google owns YouTube
Google has done a lot for language very
anytime you're in doubt as to whether
phrases is valid or not or how a word is
spelled is Google and you get the answer
right away you're looking for grammar
resources how to conjugate a verb
google it then you have Google Translate
which is a tremendous resource but for
example here if I read in this book I
mean I come across a lot of words that I
don't know I simply type them all into
Google Translate I'll get a list of 20
or 30 accumulated over 20 or 30 pages or
10 pages
so I see the meaning right away and then
I copy pasted all of those and import
those into link and I go through them
again and then
and example phrases from our library and
a whole bunch of stuff like that is
phenomenal
I also one thing I do in Google
Translate is I'll say something in
English I'll turn the Google Translate
for example English to Romanian I'll
just in anticipation say before I have
my conversation I'll just say a whole
bunch of stuff in English pops the
Romanian I grab the Romanian I imported
into link I go through it granted that
translation is not perfect and I'm not
you know that but it's not an influence
my my my language but it's gonna give me
a lot of words and phrases that I can
use in the conversation there again
Google Translate so I criticize YouTube
at the beginning but YouTube / Google
has given us a lot of useful tools both
for our active and our passive language
learning thank you for listening bye for
now